the new project dropped yeah
uh
you've been super active man i feel like
uh we just talked
before this album came out you had
dropped something else yeah i dropped
like like four mixtapes yeah you've been
on your [ __ ] bro like um
is that like do you do that [ __ ] on
purpose cause you know sometimes
i feel like artists they make the
mistake of doing the opposite of that
they'll drop they'll get a buzz and then
they overthink the next thing and then
people don't care anymore when they drop
new [ __ ] shout out to g rico mozzie
like
i'll be just
listening to them
and they know
you're in a position where you always
tell me drop g don't like you feel me
like the flood [ __ ] like i already like
was paying attention to g and listen to
g caught me all the time and be like
bro like he just called me three days
ago you like
i'm good
doing what you're supposed to do drop
again you feel what i'm saying
and you're in a position where you can
do that i'm ready yeah shout out to
empire oh my god y'all the empire
everybody
is this narrative out there that
rootsy could do whatever you want to do
with the empire bro like i've been doing
interviews and they said yeah i heard
you could do whatever you want to do at
empire like
i just think that
when you sign to a label it's on you bro
either you hot or you [ __ ] not bro
yeah sometimes people sign
and then they stop working because they
think all right cool i signed now
they're gonna do all the work
and i got the music together it's like
nah when you sign you gotta turn up your
work ethic bro gas up bro
being a face bro that's all it's about
and that's all i've been doing yeah
that's crazy because the first record i
ever heard from you uh the homie salas
had played me the uh silas the lean like
a trollo remake mm-hmm
and i just i was just trying to catch
what was that like four years ago
that's when i was really trying to cater
to all my hispanic fans like
that's where it's at
type c yeah that was uh is that even
like on dsps
i don't know
like could i go into hey lean like
totally on dsps holiday
oh yeah great record did you ever talk
to down aka kilo yeah they what they was
on they was on something remember
he was cool though yeah down aka kilo
yeah that's crazy they like
it's crazy when i did it i'm like
i didn't really give a [ __ ] i'm just i'm
about to just put it out like you know
what i'm saying
when it hit me up i'm like oh damn it
was fast though like and i wasn't even
that hot at that moment right hit me up
that was
getting out there type [ __ ]